we have a responsibility to render Aid
yeah you know civil liability is a big
deal when you're a cop at any given time
you can lose everything because you fail
to follow one part of your job
description rendering Aid is one of them
civil law has ruined everything civil
law has destroyed our country it really
has and Americans they love civil law
there's so many people getting rich yeah
no off civil law
man but the mental the mental
the mental expense and the emotional
expense of all of that type of stuff all
those rules the laws the impossibility
of it that the average human the average
American I think because this is a
really a lot of its American issues uh I
think we're getting to the point where
we're at our Tipping Point a lot of
people are on medication a lot of people
are stressed beyond the gills we can't
people are not
um able to have children as easily
anymore everybody's going through all
this fertilization you know stuff I
think there's tons of stressors
um I think we're getting to that point
where
it's a little bit at their Tipping Point
you don't know what a CVS now if you are
safe or not you know like I was there
the other day
in the makeup Lady is now tussling with
some [__] 6'4 man in there yeah and
she's just trying to
you know make sure that this God doesn't
mash up her station you know like is the
guy's running around taking stuff right
and so then like you have people who
they have to be enforcers now and she's
just a makeup person and the photo guy
you know it's like they shouldn't have
to be enforcers so it's like
um and then the truth is they probably
should just let Insurance handle it or
whatever you know so it's like
I don't know we've just gotten ourselves
into this place it feels like a lot of
times where
the people who are supposed to be
helping us our therapists our police or
the people that are kind of like add
this buffer to society to make us stay
well
um are kind of stressed to the gills it
feels like sometimes yeah I don't know
who's gonna police the world coming up
especially now with everything that's
going on who's going into law
enforcement right now yeah what's that
been like has there been lower amounts
of people going in have you heard or
anything uh no I mean I I they're it's
but it seems scary yeah they've
tightened the standards they've made it
harder because the world's going like oh
you know the police are doing everything
they can to go we need the we need the
best candidates we don't want these
problems again in the future
the test thing process of becoming a
police officer is it's extraordinary I
mean it's really extraordinary the tests
I had to go through you know
psychologists uh written tests physical
tests
um I mean there's just so many
interviews backgrounds they went in my
background they went and talked to
everybody no oh dude everybody they talk
to my ex-girlfriends and everybody
that's a good one and they also seal it
and they so you never get to know what
they said which is really well you
should get it when you're done dude on
the way out I knew where it was and I
thought many times I'm gonna go in there
and [__] pill with this [__] but I
didn't want to [__] with my pension who
knows what they could do you know what I
mean so but the who's going to police
who's going to do it who's going to take
this job
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one